estaban en pleno examen En un colegio
del Oeste de kabul la capital afgana
cuando de repente se vieron envueltos en
una explosión en lo que las autoridades
han denominado como un atentado
terrorista contra La minoría chi hija
Sara de la zona
la explosión se produjo en el lugar
donde estaban sentadas las chicas ellas
estaban en Primera fila y nosotros los
chicos estábamos detrás de ellas
[Música]
los estudiantes estaban preparando para
el examen de ingreso a la universidad
entre ellos mujeres que enfrentan una
situación muy difícil para tener acceso
a la enseñanza con los institutos
femeninos cerrados no obstante Si tienen
acceso a la educación privada y a pesar
de ser arriesgado muchas como jusnia
hassigni deciden arriesgarse por su
futuro
esta mañana salió de casa y se fue para
asistir al examen le dije no vayas a
clase pero ella me dijo no me voy cuando
fuimos al hospital de urgencias
recibimos una llamada del hospital
diciendo que había encontrado el cadáver
de mi hermana
un episodio que ha sembrado el temor
entre la población víctima de múltiples
atentados similares desde que los
talibanes ascendieron al poder
[Música]
mamá mamá Esperamos que la comunidad
internacional el gobierno de El emiratos
islámico y las instituciones de Derechos
Humanos persigan este asunto busquen una
solución y encuentren la raíz de Tales
ataques porque esta serie de asesinatos
selectivos no se pueden repetir
este atentado es muy similar a un
atentado contra un centro educativo en
2020 que dejó 24 muertos y fue
reivindicado por el estado islámico